día 5 de liar en el calendario hebreo y
del luto por el recuerdo de sus soldados
caídos y víctimas del terrorismo israel
pasa a celebrar el aniversario 74 de la
creación de su estado la conmemoración
de este año ocurre de la noche del
miércoles a la jornada del jueves inició
con el encendido de antorchas en el
monte herzl y cuenta con diversos
eventos culturales y la realización de
picnics barbacoas y conciertos entre
otros actos de que por primera vez en
dos años se desarrollan casi sin
restricciones por la pandemia
esto es muy emocionante extrañaba a
salir a las calles y celebrar y para mí
israel significa independencia y
libertad para ser judía para estar en la
calle y estar orgulloso de mí y de mis
creencias
a esta fecha el gobierno israelí llega
al mando de una coalición con inédita
presencia árabe algo destacado por el
primer ministro naftalí bennett en su
mensaje aunque marcado por su fragilidad
y lejos de estar dispuesto a un diálogo
serio que resuelva el conflicto entre
israelíes y palestinos para estos
últimos este día no es de festejo o
independencia sino que marca la nakba o
catástrofe en referencia al hecho de
forzado que cientos de miles de
palestinos sufrieron desde la guerra
árabe-israelí de 1948 hasta hoy
si me preguntas por mis sentimientos
como árabe este es mi país y no me
siento tranquilo porque vivo en
condiciones difíciles sobre todo con los
judíos
no nos sentimos con libertad de ir a
donde queramos y hacer lo que queramos
estuvo activo for one
la controversia en torno a este día
sumar a este jueves una exhibición de la
fuerza aérea israelí que planea
sobrevolar hebrón en la cisjordania
ocupada un movimiento catalogado de
provocación por la izquierda israelí y
organizaciones palestinas